bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire la dernière de cette
saison bonjour katia bonjour ni quelle
est l'actualité cette semaine c'était
prévisible
le gouvernement a enclenché le 49-3 sur
la loi travail pas de deuxième débat à
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre a voulu clore ces débats les
fraudeurs n'ont pas déposé deux motions
de censure
la tension reste vive flamme à gauche
des heures de l'audition et des
propositions parfois un choc une premier
point d'étape pour la commission d'
enquête parlementaire mise en place
après les attentats qui ont frappé la
france les députés soulignent certaines
failles et propose notamment une refonte
du renseignement le rapport sera rendu
le 12 juillet prochain
une fin de semaine marquée par les
hommages des hommage à michel rocard
hommage national dans la cour des
invalides personnalités de gauche bien
sûr mais de droite réunis pour dire un
dernier adieu à l'ancien premier
ministre
et pour commenter cette riche semaine
notre invité georges fenech bonjour vous
êtes député les républicains du rhône et
président de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire qui était mise en place
après les attentats de 2015 on y
reviendra longuement notamment sur les
propositions de la commission aussi sur
les vôtres mais d'abord je vous propose
de dérouler le film de la semaine avec
d'abord lundi manuel valls qui fait le
voyage en corse premier déplacement pour
le premier ministre sur l'île une visite
mouvementée déplacement à hauts risques
politiques points sensibles l'amnestie
éventuelle des prisonniers et le statut
de l'île stefana malien le premier
ministre est resté sourd à plusieurs
revendications de l'exécutif corse
dirigée depuis décembre 2015 par gilles
simeoni
membre du parti nationaliste principales
revendications
l'obtention du statut de langue
officielle pour le corse au même titre
que le français est la création du
statut de résident de l'île
deux requêtes catégoriquement refusée
par le premier ministre des lignes
rouges à ne pas franchir
le chef du gouvernement a toutefois fait
un pas en avant en annonçant la création
d'une agrégation en langue corse un
effort jugé insuffisant mais je vous
surprendrai pas en disant que d'un point
de vue politique
nous sommes déçus par l'attitude des
premiers ministres et par son discours
qui n'est pas à notre avis à la hauteur
des enjeux actuels
autre dossier sensible l'aministie de ce
que le gouvernement refuse d'appeler
prisonniers politiques
le premier ministre a rappelé que les
règles du rapprochement pourront
s'appliquer à l'exception des membres du
commando erignac qui resteront
incarcérés sur le continent
la visite de manuel valls portait avant
tout sur la création de la collectivité
unique corse
elle devra prendre effet au 1er janvier
2018 elle remplacera les deux
départements actuels cette collectivité
unique qui est une démarche inédite
c'est là aussi une nouvelle page de la
décentralisation
c'est la preuve que nous vous faisons
confiance pour vous de saisir au mieux
des questions qui vous concerne et de
votre avenir
le programme exceptionnel
d'investissements financés par l'état a
lui aussi été reconduits tout comme le
régime fiscal dérogatoire pour lutter
contre l'augmentation de l'immobilier
corse
georges fenech est ce que manuel valls a
raison d'être ferme sur ce dossier corse
sur le statut sur la langue c'est vrai
écoutez d'abord il a raison quand il dit
qu'il n'y a pas de prisonniers
politiques mais je ne suis pas d'accord
quand on dit que le gouvernement refuse
de les considérer comme des poux c'est
la justice qui le dit si c'est un détenu
de droit commun ou un condamné le régime
politique parce que le régime des
tensions et de pénitencier est différent
relève de la justice sur la justice ce
sont des crimes et délits de droit
commun et les condamnés purgent des
peines de droit comme donc madame disant
impossible je ne vois pas au nom de quoi
il y aurait une amnistie
les élus corses à vous n'aurez que
j'entends bien mais enfin écoutez le
préfet erignac
de même c'était un crime de la plus
haute gravité la justice a tranché à
établir les responsabilités un condamné
il faut que la justice soit même de
rapprochement donc pour cette prise
aussi à la clé et les rapprochements
risque
fonds à vous le savez très bien à la
prison de borgo et des rapprochements ce
qui est normal familiaux mais sur la les
faits concernant le préfet erignac
effectivement il ya un refus sur ce
rapprochement pour des raisons j'imagine
d'ordre public
faut-il que je ne conteste pas faut-il
un statut spécifique pour la corse
est ce que le maillage actuel actuel est
suffisant ou pas qu'est ce que vous
préconisez des statuts spécifiques on en
a connu plusieurs pour la corse
maintenant l'heure est venue à retrouver
une unité de lille je dirais à mettre un
terme en 2018
deux départements et la région faire une
collectivité entière
moi je suis assez séduit tu veux dire
par par cette idée je pense aussi les
corses très majoritairement ont toujours
un temps d'avancé comme il le disait sur
ces réformes territoriales un temps
avant ce qui avait le temps avance des
corses et corse
ils sont les premiers concernés il ya
des aspirations qui sont légitimes sur
la langue corse moi je trouve
l'inspiration tout à fait légitime de
promouvoir ce qui est une véritable lune
la langue corse
de là à l'officialiser comme deuxième
langue officielle non nous sommes la
corse appartient je rejoins là aussi le
gouvernement à la république entière une
et indivisible
il n'y a pas deux peuples il n'y a pas à
ma nation française est pas un peuple
français est un peuple corse vous
souvenez la réforme constitutionnelle
d'ailleurs sous michel rocard la censure
constitutionnelle qui avait supprimé le
la technologie de peuple corse donc moi
je suis pour développer effectivement la
langue corse reconnaître comme une
langue à part entière d'ailleurs ce
diplôme d'agrégation est tout à fait
bien bienvenue mais pas au delà
alors on va passer au mardi la
commission d' enquête sur les attentats
dont vous êtes le président a rendu ses
conclusions
pas de huit mois après les attentats du
13 novembre des dizaines d'auditions
georges fenech vous êtes donc le
président de cette commission va voir
les détails que tu était proposé dans
ses conclusions de ce rapport
récit signé thibault le floch est
évidemment on n'en parle plus à la
principale faille mise en avant par la
commission denquête c'est celle des
services de renseignement lors de son
audition devant la commission
le directeur général de la sécurité
extérieure résume l'ampleur de cet échec
des attentats comme ceux du 13 novembre
marque bien un échec du renseignement
extérieur ils ont été planifiés à
l'extérieur de nos frontières est
organisé en belgique
c'est à dire dans l'air de compétence de
la dgs ils représentent aussi sans doute
un échec pour le renseignement intérieur
dans la mesure où ils se sont produits
sur notre sol les députés font le
constat que les services de
renseignement sont trop divisés et
qu'ils ne communiquent pas assez entre
eux il propose donc de créer une agence
nationale de l'antiterrorisme chargé de
coordonner l'ensemble des services anti
terroristes comme l'ont fait les
américains après les attentats du 11
septembre le nctc américain c'est 1200
agents notre coordonnateur auprès du
président lui ces huit agents qui
coordonne quoi donc nous voulons une
agence de lutte contre le terrorisme qui
non seulement gère une base commune du
renseignement qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui mais également qui analyse
la menace et qui met en place une
véritable stratégie opérationnelle de
contre terrorisme
les députés déplorent également le
manque de coordination des agences de
renseignement au niveau européen et ils
prennent l'exemple de salades des slams
contrôlé par la gendarmerie française
près de la frontière belge
au lendemain du 13 novembre les services
belges possèdent une fiche sur lui mais
elles n'indiquent pas acquis les
radicaliser et qu'il peut porter
atteinte à la sûreté de l'état
au bout d'une demi-heure le véhicule
reprend sa route pour se fondre dans la
nature
la refonte des services de renseignement
préconisée par les députés est d'une
ampleur jamais atteinte et les victimes
de ces attaques espère que ces
préconisations seront suivies d'effet
on ne sait pas qui va décider on ne sait
pas quelles sont les budgets rond ne
sais pas quels sont les calendriers et
aujourd'hui on al'impression finalement
qu'on nous dépose ce rapport et puis
finalement qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant c'est la grande interrogation
le rapport sera publié dans son
intégralité le 12 juillet prochain avec
la retranscription des auditions il fera
plus de 1000 pages alors on danse est un
petit peu plus car une proposition ce
sont vos conclusions
simplement le 12 juillet comme viennent
de le rappeler thibault on veut savoir
un petit peu plus
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire que
nous ne sache pas encore on a développé
publiquement laissant la totalité de nos
40 propositions qui est le fruit d'un
travail important profond dick et durer
cinq mois
avec tout de même quelques 190 personnes
auditionnées 200 heures d'audition
plusieurs déplacements à l'étranger
plusieurs visites de nos services en
france donc c'est un vrai travail très
sérieux croyez moi qui a été fait par
mes collègues parlementaires
le rapporteur à qui je rends hommage et
moi même qui me suis vraiment investi
dans cette commission des requêtes
alors que vous dire de plus que ce que
nous avons dit il ya beaucoup de choses
il ya beaucoup de choses le rapport
revient en détail sur un grand nombre de
points que nous pouvions pas développé
de cette manière là ce d'autant que le
rapport n'est pas public encore il le
sera effectivement le 12 et d'autre part
vous aurez accès aux annexes qui
contiennent toutes les auditions y
compris les auditions nous avons fait à
huit clos intégralement intégralement
publié tout est ce qu'on apprend des
choses
donc nous ne savons pas est-ce que vous
pouvez aujourd'hui nous
délivré quelques messages de ce qu'il ya
dans ces rapports de ces par exemple de
c2c commission à huis clos que vous avez
tenus écoutez je vois un extrait je sais
pas commencé à fuiter parce que
nécessairement toujours les fuites
vous avez vu l'audition de monsieur
bajolet le patron de la dgse
ça c'est pas dans l'autre aura dans
l'eau conclusion c'est dans le rapport
ce que vous venez de rediffuser à
l'écran monsieur bajolet le patron des
services extérieurs reconnaît avec
beaucoup de lucidité d'honnêteté c'est
un échec de nos services
c'est un échec du renseignement
extérieur et vous verrez dans les
auditions notamment le patron de la dgsi
renseignement intérieur je sais qu'elle
va dit la même chose il y a une volonté
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la vérité parce
que les faits sont trop graves
la menace est trop persistante et nous
le devons aux victimes et aux français
donc il s'agit pas de pointer du doigt
des responsables il s'agit de dire où ça
n'a pas fonctionné
oui donc vous dites il ya une nécessité
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la vérité ce
qui sous-entend que peut-être toute la
vérité n'a pas encore été faite que vous
vous avez peut-être encore des choses à
dire nous avons apporté une pierre
importante dans ce débat ce que j'espère
c'est que cette commission d' enquête ne
soit pas maltraité ne sont pas
maltraitées comme elle l'a été mais je
vous le dis très clairement j'ai été
consterné n'est véritablement consterné
par la réponse du ministre l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve mercredi dernier aux
questions d'actualité bien parlé donnant
le pudding pour qui sur exactement
choisi c'est inacceptable sur une
question du rapporteur de sa majorité en
plus je sébastien pietrasanta qui ne
considère pas les travaux de l'été venez
à nous dire que ce que nous proposons
c'est du poum pudding j'imagine enfant
roux c'est à dire vous rajouter au
millefeuille vous compliqué c'est une
injure c'est une injure à notre travail
c'est un mépris c'est une arrogance
c'est une suffisance je le dis comme je
le pense
et en tant que président de la
commission denquête je ne laisserai pas
faire c'est à dire qu'elle suit pouvez
vous donner c'est à dire que quand un
ministre vous dis 24 heures après la
remise du rapport votre apport il ne
vaut rien il ne m'intéresse pas en gros
c'est ça circulez ya rien à voir
ça n'est pas acceptable parce que à
travers notre commission denquête c'est
tout le rôle du contrôle du parlement
sur l'action exécutif qui est en cause
un ministre ne peut pas à lui tout seul
dire ce qu'a fait les parlementaires de
toutes sensibilités confondues 30
parlementaire
vous êtes à côté de la plaque non non il
faut d'abord recevoir le rapport
l'étudier nous recevoir
engager un dialogue avant de jeter comme
ça te plairait aux orties si je
comprends bien ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui vous pensez que bernard
cazeneuve de donnera absolument où je
vous livre je vous dis que je suis très
en colère
je suis vraiment très en colère et on ne
lâchera pas le rapporteur moi même et
les membres des commissions dans lequel
on ne peut pas accepter que le ministre
qui endosse la plus lourde
responsabilité politique sur l'année
2015 puissent venir nous dire tout ce
que vous avez fait ne m'intéresse pas je
ne sais pas pour se refaire appel acquis
au président de la république mais bien
entendu nous allons monter au plus haut
niveau de l'état et nous allons demander
une mission la création d'une mission
d'information parlementaire à la
commission des lois pour que nous
puissions assurer le suivi nos
propositions voir ce qu'elle devienne
comment elles sont prises en compte par
les différents ministres concernés n'y a
pas que lui misé l'intérieur émises la
défense il ya le ministre de la justice
est inscrite à la secrétaire d'état
chargé des victimes
et donc nous allons exercer notre
contrôle un républicain sans arrière
pensée politicienne un contrôle
républicain de cette mission d'informer
vous la demanderaient très bientôt
cette lui si je l' ai déjà demandé vous
êtes vous allé répond nous allons
officialiser cette demande
l'accord a été donné de principe et il
est évident vous avez bien d'accord de
france j'ai eu un accord de principe du
président de la commission des lois
encore il est évident que création toute
prochaine de cette mission de fruits
alors une mission d'information c'est
léger c'est pas une commission denquête
moins de pouvoirs que la commission de
moins de pouvoir mais quand même la
possibilité d'aller dans les mystères
d'auditionner les ministres de rendre
compte à la commission des lois de
rentrer compte à l'assemblée du travail
qui va être fait maintenant par le
gouvernement parce que si demain
imaginons que de maya nouveau bataclan
quelle sera la réponse de l'exécutif
vous laventie le faire
interroge-t-elle augmenter le nombre de
frappes en syrie comme le président la
république a décidé recommencer un débat
interminable sur la déchéance de
nationalité
on voit bien qu'on se trompe de solution
la solution elle est en grande partie
dans ce que nous apportons c'est à dire
que nous avons déceler les failles très
grave préjudiciables notamment au niveau
du renseignement et un certain nombre
d'autres questions une des propositions
chaque veau préconisé une fusion des
forces d'élite certains n'y sont pas
favorables parce qu'on dit qu'il faut
que chaque force garde sa spécificité
opérationnel est ce que vous préconisez
par exemple quelque chose comme ce qui
existe avec le cos le commandement des
opérations spéciales où il ya un
commandement unifié les chaque force
garde chacun mais garde sa spécificité
écoutez on est dans un pays de tradition
de culture c'est très difficile d'aller
contre les je dirais les guerres de
chapelles où les pré carré quels sont
ils sont au service ils sont là et nous
vivons avec cela nous vivons avec
aujourd'hui pour cette question-là trois
forces d'élite vous savez la brigade de
recherche et d'intervention pour paris
le ggn la gendarmerie et le raid à prix
social qu'on me dise pourquoi conserver
trois forces d'élite pourquoi ne alors
avec toutes les gares desservies ce
qu'on peut imaginer et à l'occasion du
bataclan il y aurait beaucoup à dire
1 pourquoi ne pas fusionner c'est en
tout cas un sujet qui pour moi n'est pas
été refusée par les internes ont même
utilisateur il refuse tout cas toute
façon vous allez le voir vous avez tort
il a réussi à l'ogre avec lui car moi je
veux bien c'est les français qui
jugeront un certain moment de cette
attitude qui consiste à dire vous avez
toujours tort j'ai toujours raison c'est
un peu ça je suis dans la compassion je
vais effectivement il ne dit pas que
rien n'a été fait il ya des choses qui
ont été faits depuis depuis 2015 à moi à
mon goût trop tardivement
il aurait fallu les faire immédiatement
après l'hyper cacher et charlie hebdo
on a attendu en novembre on mettre en
place des véritables mesures telles que
l'équipement des bacs et des psig sabres
en armes lourdes dont les prix - avec
vos dès aujourd'hui la création de cette
mission d'information vous l'avez ont
quasiment obtenu on est d'accord
j'attends qu'elle soit officialisée mais
de toute manière on ne peut pas
effectivement remettre ce travail
et puis partir en vacances même si on
est au mois de juillet c'est pas
possible
d'autant que la menace est très élevé
nous voyons ce qui se passe actuellement
l'attentât dernier en dernier en date à
bagdad de 113 morts nous sommes allés
aux etats-unis le jour même d'attentât
d' orlando
nous sommes allés en belgique le
lendemain des attentats malheureusement
des hasards de calendriers à la station
de métro de bruxelles
on voit bien que le terrorisme risque
encore que le rapido voilà à passer à
une autre actualité georges fenech
c'était à nouveau mardi à l'assemblée
nationale le gouvernement a utilisé ce
fameux article du 49-3 qui lui permet de
faire une sorte de passage en force
cette explication signé stéphanie des
pierres jeu 15 heures devant les députés
le premier ministre
acte le recours aux 49 3 je ne veux pas
laisser certains mettent en scène les
divisions alimenter les fractures jouer
oui jouer avec les institutions aller à
des fins politiciennes qui ne prennent
pas en compte l'intérêt général et celui
des français c'est pourquoi j'ai donc
décidé d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement avant même la fin du
discours de manuel valls
les députés de droite quitte l'hémicycle
le débat verrouiller le bazar dans la
rue écouter une mascarade et maintenant
rendez vous dans neuf mois devant les
électeurs l'ailé gauche du ps dénonce
cette seconde utilisation du 49-3 sur la
loi travail aujourd'hui le pays a besoin
de démocratie et de solutions crédibles
face au chômage
on lui inflige une grande violence avec
un nouvel usage de l'article 49 3
jusqu'au dernier moment il ya une
tentative de compromis au sein de la
majorité socialiste
lundi environ 120 députés ps avaient
déposé un amendement sur la majoration
des heures supplémentaires s'il était
adopté
les frondeurs était prêt à voter la loi
travail mais mardi matin la réunion du
groupe ps a été très agité et manuel
valls leur signifie une fin de non
recevoir
on nous répond tout compromis est une
compromission en d'autres termes
manuel valls a raison sur tout et qui
n'est pas sur sa position et
irresponsable je pense qu'à travers
cette forme d'intransigeance et de
brutalité ont créé les conditions d'un
échec collectif de la gauche à l'issue
de la réunion mardi matin les députés
comprenne qu'il y aura 49 3 la loi
travail sera donc adopté sans discussion
le texte repartira au sénat pourquoi
vous n'avez pas déposé deux motions de
censure après l'utilisation de 49,3 voix
à droite parce que je pense qu'il faut
un peu incertain - respecter les
français les français sont échaudés
maintenant par ce débat interminable
comme il l'avait été par nous et je
venais de n'être pas d'accord que la
politique du gouvernement il ya une
possibilité si on l'a déjà déposé vous
savez très bien on a déjà déposé une
motion de censure lors du premier
passage 49,3 qui n'a pas été acceptée
maintenant c'est un débat entre la
gauche et la gauche à nous on est
malheureusement observateurs et comme
l'a très bien dit christian jacob
les français trancheront dans quelques
mois comment vous observez un peu ce qui
se passe à gauche oh mais ce qui se
passe à gauche c'est que cette
utilisation à répétition du 49 3 2 puis
vous souvenez la loi macro jusqu'à
maintenant répétition la loi comme riz
c'est la démonstration qu'il n'y a plus
de majorité au sein du gouvernement et
qu'il y a deux gauches qui ont
complètement explosé et que donc en
l'absence de majorité le gouvernement
heureusement qu'il ne reste plus que
quelques mois
est ce que je vaux pas comment peut
diriger ce pays sans majorité politique
les franches et rend les français
trancheront dans quelques mois vous avez
dit si la droite revient au pouvoir et
ce qu'elle n'a bronze racette loi
travail mais qu'est ce qu'il reste de
cette loi s qui aura vraiment besoin de
quelque chose de cette loi travail de ta
prétendants au début c'est intéressant
d'avoir ces accords de branche qui
et qui est
devait céder devant des accords
d'entreprise quand il y avait un accord
dans les entreprises saines et ce
pénible plus de souplesse le conte tout
ça a été beaucoup aller dans le sens de
la souplesse pour l' embauche les
indemnités en tête en cas de
licenciement économique plafonné tout ça
nous allait très bien et puis ensuite
49,3 pas de majorité le débat dans la
rue ça revient dans l'hémicycle s'est
modifié au sénat le 20 ans aujourd'hui
c'est peau de chagrin parce qu'il ya
quand même eu pas mal de recul qui a été
fait donc je pense qu'ils vont se fondre
à quand la droite reviendra parce que je
ne peux pas douter qu'une alternance
autrement je vous en dirai dans le mur
il va falloir effectivement une nouvelle
et grande loi sur le travail
alors c'est une action pour suivre cette
émission avec mercredi leur qui est au
renouveau et au renoncement plus tôt le
gouvernement a détaillé les grands axes
de son budget pour 2010 est la hausse
des dépenses et tous les importantes que
prévu 6,8 milliards d'euros de plus
conséquence est bien le gouvernement
renonce à son objectif d'économies marie
vraiment oublier les 50 milliards
d'euros d'économies promis il ya deux
mois à la commission européenne
oubliez les bonnes résolutions
budgétaires le gouvernement prévoit une
augmentation des dépenses de 5,6
milliards d'euros par rapport au montant
envisagé dans le programme de stabilité
2016 2019
en cause les nouvelles dépenses
annoncées comme le dégel du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires le soutien à
l'élevage ou le renforcement des moyens
de la police
mais pour l'opposition c'est avant tout
l'illustration d'une mauvaise gestion
budgétaire et de cadeaux électoraux
engagé à neuf mois de l'élection
présidentielle
malheureusement ces annonces à crédit et
on profite peut être un peu de la
certitude en europe en ce moment avec le
loto mauldre excite pour se dire la
commission veut être plus accommodante
avec la france profitons-en pour faire
des cadeaux électoraux payées à crédit
mais pour les socialistes pas de
changement de cap l'essentiel est
ailleurs
non l'objectif n'est pas remis en cause
objectif c'est d'atteindre un déficit
inférieur à 3 % en 2017
voilà c'est l'objectif un optimisme non
partagé par la cour des comptes très
sceptique sur les objectifs affichés
pour 2010 est georges fenech une
question après les promesses l'heure et
on renonce m'en ont parlé vous aussi de
renoncement savez on le dit souvent le
président hollande a été lue sur un
grand mensonge on devait s'attaquer à la
finance est en réalité il nomme accro
aux finances il y avait plein de bonnes
résolutions départ et ç'a été une
succession effectivement de renoncement
et aujourd'hui on ouvre carrément les
robinets et on sent que les élections
arrivent les grandes échéances arrivent
et donc on veut se poudrer voilà on ne
tient pas en réalité le niveau de la
dépense publique à laquelle on s'était
engagés y compris vis-à-vis nos
partenaires européens
là ils m'ont maintien qui sera en
dessous des 2% à 20 19 il ne me
souvenais l'a toujours dit qu'il allait
inverser la courbe du chômage on attend
toujours l'inversion vous ne croyez pas
je ne crois pas parce que vous savez un
moment fini par être échaudé un canton
vous mord à répétition donc on a un
niveau de dépenses publiques qui
augmentent on a toujours un matraquage
fiscal quoi qu'on en dise le leur sort
économique même s'il ya une légère
inflexion aujourd'hui n'est pas
suffisant pour créer de l'emploi
la loi du travail on sait ce qu'elle est
en train de devenir donc les entreprises
se ferait à nouveau on arrive vraiment
dans une situation très problématique
pourtant nous devons comme tous nos
partenaires en terre respecter des
désengagements pacte de stabilité
est ce que si la droite revient au
pouvoir elle fera preuve cette fois ci
de sagesse budgétaire t on à un projet
en tout cas nous les républicains nous
avons fait adopter au conseil national
sous la présidence nicolas sarkozy à un
programme de dépenses drastiques
l'assemblée a représenté comme il ya un
la dépense publique donc on a un vrai
programme économique qui nous sommes à
engager là dessus bien entendu toute
façon il n'y a pas le choix
regardez ce qu'ont fait les allemands
ont regardé ce qu'on fait aussi les
mieux on n'a pas le choix il faut
véritable avec un niveau de dette
publique les 100 % oui on en est à peu
près effectivement à 2000 milliards je
crois que le pressent pour cent du pib
avait recueilli toujours aussi d'un
rapport sur l'organisation de l'islam en
france il porte la responsabilité des
musulmans mais aussi les ambiguïtés de
l'état regarder cette synthèse signé
vous dire soucis passés d'un islam en
france un islam de france
la nuance est mince mais essentiel dans
son rapport d'information la mission du
sénat identifie plusieurs axes de
travail pour permettre cette transition
premier objectif former les imams sur le
territoire aujourd'hui 300 un imam
étrangers détaché en france prêche dans
les 2500 lieux cultes répertorié une
présence précieuse mais pas forcément
adaptée quand les religieux ont une
maîtrise limitée du français aujourd'hui
trois établissements de formation existe
dans le pays il est évident que cette
connaissance du contexte français est
indispensable lorsqu'on veut
véritablement rencontré la population
et tenir un discours
religieux à son égard on ne peut pas
comme ça il faut le texte dans le
contexte le rapport révèle une fracture
entre les fidèles et leur organe de
représentation
le cfcm créé en 2003 souffre d'un
déficit de légitimité dessinateur
appelle les responsables du conseil
français du culte musulman à se réformer
pour rétablir le lien semblerait logique
que l'ensemble des différentes
associations fédérations tendance puisse
être représenté dans cette instance
puisque les musulmans en france sont
divers les luttes de pouvoir entre élus
algériens marocains ou turcs paralyse
les instances la place des financements
étrangers est aussi déterminant pour
l'autonomie de l'islam français afin de
lever les doutes les suspicions la
mission propose que tous les fonds
l'étranger transitent par la fondation
des oeuvres islamique pour permettre une
traçabilité et une transparence
incontestable s à l'état d'organiser
l'islam en france oui je pense que
l'état a son mot à dire dans le respect
évidemment la séparation des églises et
de l'état
je pense que l'état doit veiller à ce
que chaque citoyen français puissent
exercer librement son culte dont qu'il a
il a son mot à dire notamment en matière
de financement des lieux de culte
même s'il ne peut pas lui même financé
les lieux parmi les enjeux majeurs il ya
aussi la question de la formation des
imams former des imams français c'est
possible vous voyez les choses moi je
considère que c'est une question
centrale aujourd'hui dans notre société
qu'est l'islam en france l'islam de
france comme on dit le point islam en
france
en france c'est toute la caisse vieille
question qui a été posée à l'époque de
nicolas sarkozy ce absolument et qui se
pose toujours
il faut donc bien voir que les dérives
auxquelles nous assistons aujourd'hui
son dérives que non plus que combat
combattre que fier en inde une religion
une confession qui sont organisés et qui
vais justement contre ces dérives comme
l'ont fait les autres les autres grandes
religions
donc je pense que il faut revoir
effectivement le fonctionnement de ce
conseil force et musulmans ou surtout
surtout que toutes les tendances de
l'islam soit représentée au sein de ce
conseil et puis
le financement qui reste la clé quand on
sait que du financement qui vient
d'algérie de turbide arabie saoudite
qu'est ce qui a en échange de ces
financements
mais qu'est-ce que vous proposeriez à la
place on voit qu'elle quand même une
certaine opacité dans les fonds les
sénateurs proposent des de collecter en
france les fonds parle d'une redevance
halal sur le halal que vous en pensez à
une redevance privé taxe pour tout le
monde attention avant d'accéder n
moi je pense est une bonne idée cela
cette redevance privé sur organisé par
sur halal ça pourrait le marché est
important donc ça pourrait dégager
et puis il faut que les fidèles et my
fasse l'effort de données je crois que
c'est la libre cotisations le du don
après que l'état facilitent la
construction de lieux de culte parce
qu'il est important que chacun puisse
exercer son cul dans des conditions
dignes
c'est aussi son rôle et je pense aussi
évidemment la formation des imams
il faut que les imams et le rapport
sénatorial qui est excellent là-dessus
me dis bien il faut aussi mal qu'ils
connaissent nos lois nos valeurs
qui parle le français et qui puisse
véhiculer à travers la confession et a
un côté de la confession musulmane le
respect aussi d'une vie non pas que ne
tarissent mais d'une vie dans une
république une et indivisible draps
cette semaine de françois fillon qui a
peut-être sonné un peu vos oreilles il
ya un certain nombre de gens à droite
qui ont une sorte de réflexe pavlovien
dès que l'on parle de l'islam ils se
mettent à éructer vite votre camp c'est
grave ça c'est grave de considérer son
islam c est la deuxième religion de
france
les salades jour de droite qui est rude
quand ils entendent parler distance
fillon qui dit cela à écouter non
vraiment je crois qu'il faut faire
attention à ne pas jeter ses anathèmes
parce que alors il y en a peut-être
c'est vrai mais quand aussi tu es
quelqu'un comme ça vous avez tendance
enfin généralisée et canton non je pense
que les responsables politiques sérieux
et responsables savent et considère et
ont deux excellentes relations avec ce
qui est encore une fois la deuxième
religion de france
mais encore faut-il que cette religion
soit mieux organisé qu'on évite les
dérives qu'on arrête avec les mosquées
salafistes ou on entendra est-ce que
françois fillon aux côtés moi je pense
pas j'ai j'aime boire tout cas j'ai
jamais entendu ce type 2 de réaction
alors encore un petit mot de politique
et d'un homme qui ne finalement ne sera
pas candidat nicolas hulot puisqu'il a
renoncé à se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
une décision qui rebat un peu les cartes
chez les verts et plus généralement à
gauche
georges fenech est ce que pour vous la
voix de nicolas hulot va manquer moi je
pense que nicolas hulot est loin de ne
plus faire entendre sa voix
je pense qu'il a d'autres moyens que le
vecteur politique je dirais pour se
faire entendre et ce il se fera d'autant
mieux entendre effectivement qu'il ne
politisent rappaz son discours comme il
l'a toujours fait jusqu'à maintenant
même si l'état partenaire groupe
écologie crois que nicolas hulot
appartient à jal tient un peu à toute la
classe politique est tous les français
d'une manière générale et c'est une
décision que je salue parce que son
combat est sincère jeudi on va passer
maintenant la journée d'hommage qui a
été rendu à michel rocard à l'hommage
rendu aux invalides pour l'ancien
premier ministre décédé le week-end
dernier de très nombreuses personnalités
de gauche ou de droite présente sur ce
dernier hommage de chef de l'état a pris
la parole vous propose d'écouter un
extrait michel rocard était une grande
et belle figure de la république une
personnalité lumineuse qui par ses
combats a marqué de son empreinte
plusieurs générations successives ici
rassemblés mais il était conscient que
les de gauche devaient s'unir pour
gouverner jamais il n'a joué contre sa
famille politique
même quand il a fallu qu'ils s'effacent
devant françois mitterrand c'était là
son honneur vous apportez vous quelque
chose michel rocard d'hommes politiques
oui moi je veux quand j'étais plus jeune
je me suis très bien son engagement la
création du parti socialiste unifié
je suis un des grands débats que nous
avions y compris narrer les campus
universitaires sur ce qui était à la
mode à l'époque l'autogestion
il a participé à auchy à mon éveil sa
deuxième gauche c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose de nouveau
réaliste avec un programme économique
tout à fait beaucoup plus réaliste
jusqu'à aurait pu séduire également des
hommes politiques venant de droite sur
cette deuxième gauche
je me sens politique réaliste comme vous
la voyez je pense qu'elle était surtout
quand on est jeune je pense que c'était
séduisant mais le le fait c'est qu'il
n'a jamais pu l'emporter et que
finalement c'est la gauche que lui-même
pouvait considérer par certains côtés un
peu archaïque
restant sur des vieux schémas qui l'a
toujours emporté avec mitterrand et avec
avec l' alliance avec les communistes et
avec la gauche de la gauche est
aujourd'hui on assiste un peu s on
assiste encore à une gauche disons a
représenté par manuel valls et emmanuel
macron qui est plus réaliste sur plan
économique qui est qui qui qui exerce le
pouvoir et qu'ils veulent exercer le
pouvoir
mais on voit bien que cette gauche là
est encore minoritaire dans le pays
darroussin à gauche
est ce que vous voyez un héritier
possible de michel rocard on avait
beaucoup de monde lors de cet hommage
aux invalides chacun revendiquant un peu
l'héritage de de michel rocard à ce que
voyait un héritier manuel valls je pense
qu'ils se sont exprimés les uns les
autres géants temps dès que vous
magnowski là qu'il a connu très jeune
effectivement et qui a inspiré sa
politique
en tout cas on sera tous les héritiers
de michel rocard sur son combat qu'il a
mené dans l'antarctique pour le climat
ça c'était son dernier grand combat de
son vivant et là dessus on peut tout son
sens ont revendiqué des de l'héritage
alors notre partenaire le figaro.fr
georges fenech nous rejoint tout de
suite c'est l'heure de la loupe du scan
bonjour georges fenech
on va reparler un peu de votre rapport
de votre commission d'un 4 sur le
terrorisme alors vous avez évoqué les
critiques émises par bernard cazeneuve
sur votre travail mais il ya eu aussi
des critiques plutôt des réserves émises
par des députés de droite comme
guillaume larrivé qui faisait partie de
la commission il a émis des réserves sur
la création d'une agence nationale de
lutte contre le terrorisme
également sur la projection de deux
troupes en irak qui comme comment
expliquer ça il ya un lien il ya une
absence de solidarité au sein de la
commission sur sur l'ensemble des
propositions pour ce qui concerne la
projection des troupes en irak c'est une
idée qui est vraiment très personnelle
aux rapporteurs de laquelle d'ailleurs
je me désolidarise aussi on en a parlé
après dans une commission denquête êtes
pas obligé d'avoir la même opinion sur
tout même quand même si vous appartenez
à la même grand politique
je suis en désaccord parce que moi j'y
suis allé à washington
j'y suis allée ou national
counterterrorism center
j'ai pu me rendre compte à quel point
après les attentats du 11 septembre
le renseignement américain s'est
totalement bouleversé transformé par un
vrai partage d'informations je suis
convaincu qu'en la coordination du
renseignement français n'est pas
positionné bon niveau c'est pour
ministre de l'intérieur a coordonnée de
tous qui n'a pas l'autorité sur mise la
défense qui a lui-même du renseignement
il n'a pas autorité sur le ministre du
budget qui a lui-même du renseignement
donc il faut coordonner au plus haut
niveau de l'état c'est un promu nice
tous présents république
et là-dessus effectivement guillaume
larrivé à une autre perception mais je
pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter entre les lignes dans les
critiques de guillaume larrivé c'est
qu'en fait le rapporteur socialiste
sébastien pietrasanta a émis ces
propositions que vous étiez amené allait
aller valider ce que ça s'est passé
comme ça on a tellement été convaincu
par ce qu'on a vu nous étions
entièrement d'accord il ya eu des
échanges entre nous pendant tous nos
trajets pendant pendant nos travaux on a
évidemment échangés en permanence on a
vécu ensemble pendant cinq mois
alors on est allé dans différents pays
et de ce qu'on en a vu on en est revenu
avec la conviction qu'il faut
restructurer complètement le
renseignement français
autre question parlons un peu la
primaire à droite le évidemment le sujet
de la lutte contre le terrorisme et
centrale quel est selon vous le candidat
qui présente l'arsenal le plus complet
sur cette question là on a un projet
celui des républicains qui a été adoptée
au conseil national
et si ce projet là qui est fondateur et
qui doit inspirer vraiment inspiré par
nicolas sarkozy
on sait toute sa sensibilité sur ces
questions de sécurité lequel j'ai changé
j'ai moi même présidé à une table ronde
sur la sécurité les soutenir pour le
lait dans la course à la primaire s'il
est candidat oui oui de la vue depuis
toujours j'ai toujours soutenu nicolas
sarkozy je continue à le soutenir parce
que je pense je pense que c'est celui
qui a plus d'expérience je pense que
c'est celui qui a encore le plus
d'énergie et de vision et en même temps
tiré aussi les échecs du passé et donc
on a tous candidats dont faut pas assez
sur le question de sécurité mais aussi
je pense que jean françois copé a une
très grande sensibilité là dessus je
pense que françois fillon aussi j'ajoute
alain juppé mais je pense que celui qui
a le plus de conviction d'expérience
pour avoir été lui même ministre de
l'intérieur c'est quand même nicolas
sachy seulement vous-même georges fenech
vous pourriez porter cette refonte
radicale du renseignement dans un
prochain gouvernement je n'ai absolument
pas cette ambition là sauf si on me l'a
demandé
nicolas sarkozy justement il propose
l'assignation à résidence pour les
fichiers c'est ce que c'est une bonne
mesure selon vous est-ce qu'elles
respectent les droits la présomption
d'innocence
attention à la fiche est ce un
instrument juridique pour contrôler et
surveiller s'il ya des conséquences de
ce type là il ya plus de fiches
est ce parce qu'un appartement
l'intrication de fiesch vs donc il sort
des radars mais ce que veut dire nicolas
sarkozy est là je le rejoins totalement
c'est cette question des gens
extrêmement dangereux notamment ceux qui
reviennent des théâtres extérieurs on
peut pas les laisser dans la nature
comme star il faut des mesures
exceptionnelles pour la nation je pense
qu'il faut tenir compte de leur état
dangereux
et que l'état s'organisent pour qu'il y
ait à titre préventif des mesures de
contrôle voire coercitives voire
assignation à résidence
voir rétention administrative limité
dans la durée sous le contrôle du juge
je suis persuadé qu'il faut expulsion
pour les redonner sorte les
ressortissants étrangers double peine
ça ça vaut le soir et ça ça fait même
plus des barjots on va changer de sujet
on va parler de d'emmanuel macron dont
on va probablement beaucoup parlé la
semaine prochaine puisqu'il va faire un
meeting un grand meeting on annonce
celle de la mutualité à paris
on annonce donc son départ prochain du
gouvernement est ce que vous le
souhaitez ce que vous appelez de vos
voeux le départ d'emmanuel les biens du
gouvernement oui ça le regarde
entièrement j'aime pas de conseils
donnés et je n'ai pas non plus de voeux
à émettre ce serait à mon avis quand
même logique de papier pris position sur
cette question notamment lors d'un
voyage de manuel valls à londres sur le
plan institutionnel oui je pense qu'il
ya une difficulté quand on est ministre
en exercice de en même temps alimenté
son parti politique
en marge de ces déplacements
ministériels moi ça me pose un problème
d anthologie vous aviez saisi la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où en
est cette saisine j'ai reçu la réponse
cette semaine
alors qui est alors je vous la donne en
primeur qui est ça ne relève pas de
notre compétence ça relève de la
compétence de la commission nationale
des comptes de campagne je ne suis pas
d'accord je vais donc répondre à nouveau
à la haute autorité pourquoi je ne suis
pas d'accord
on a créé la haute autorité pour la
transparence david public justement pour
éviter ce genre de situation moi je ne
dis pas que mes mails macron comme et
des inégalités il a le droit d'avoir un
parti de le financer
question je me pose une question de
nature déontologique la haute autorité
ne m'a pas répondu
dès qu'on pose une question difficile on
vous répond pas dans ce pays moi
j'entends est ce que la haute autorité
me répond donc je vais relancer à
nouveau la haute autorité parlons un peu
des législatives et des investitures
puisque c'est là la période dans le
rhône votre département une déléguée de
sens commun c'est le
mouvement formidable alors and learn
anne-laure exceptionnelle l échelle et
dynamique elle a des idées elle a des
convictions et je suis je suis très
heureux qu'elle soit investie presse de
son investiture
elle est aussi soutenu par laurent
wauquiez c'est une jeune femme qui est
bourré de talent et qui va certainement
décoiffé pendant cette campagne
dernière question peut-être dimanche
c'est la finale de l'euro de foot au
stade de france
est-ce que vous avez des craintes
concernant la sécurité de ce match oui
j'ai toujours des craintes à saint denis
j'ai toujours des craintes
tant que la compétition n'est pas
terminée j'ai toujours des craintes
j'espère que rien ne se produira pour
l'instant rien ne s'est produit race à
dieu mais il faut être extrêmement
vigilant
vous avez des pistes d'abord avec les
renseignements peut-être vous qui
travaillez avec la justice ce monde de
narnia après la commission vous avez
présidé vous souvenez notamment de ce
qu'on a retrouvés dans les ordinateurs
dans les messages davala quand il disait
ça va être un cimetière c'est cet euro
etc
donc il y en a une pensée effectivement
de commettre des attentats alors je
pense que quand même là les mesures ont
bien été prise quelque chose de rennes 2
une date un peu positif puisque donc
revenons sur cette belle victoire de
l'équipe de france qui a sèchement battu
l'allemagne 2 0 pour s'offrir donc une
place en finale de l'euro un petit mot
pour l'équipe de france
avant de se quitter victoire logique
tombé du ciel qu'est ce que quel a été
votre ex vous avez vu le match moi je
suis extrêmement ému par ce qui est en
train de se passer
le grisou nationale nous avions eu zizou
maintenant on a le grisou qui était
absolument extraordinaire du haut de ses
25 ans fabuleux une vraie équipe qui
fait honneur et puis vous allez
remarquer quand il ya là marseille
chants toute sa marseillaise maintenant
la célèbre marque et ben je pense que
oui je pense que quand on en a on défend
son pays qu on est patriote et que on
aime son pays qu'on aime son drapeau et
qu'on se bat pour son pays je pense que
ça peut faire marquer des buts oui vous
avez vu aussi dans les rues de paris ma
porte le drapeau français la
marseillaise entonnée oui il ya un
changement et un changement écoutez est
ce que c'est une conséquence de tous ces
drames terribles qu'on a on a vécu mais
au moins ça fait ça fait vraiment
plaisir on en est fier de retrouver une
équipe de france qui qui méritent de
porter le maillot
merci beaucoup j'en suis honnête merci
également à vous jim pour cette saison
c'est la faim de par le brave d'eau en
tout cas pour cette saison mais on se
retrouve bien entendu l'année prochaine
en tout cas passer de bonnes vacances
d'ici là on se retrouve dès septembre
avec vos mickaël szames est très bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires et merci à toute la régie
qui étaient présentes pour cette saison